an airline pilot arrested in Kentucky
could be in court as early as today in
connection with a 2015 triple homicide
Christian Martin was taken in custody
just before his flight on Saturday at
Louisville International Airport he
faces nine charges including three
counts of murder and one count of arson
Kris Van Cleave is at Reagan National
Airport just outside Washington with
more on this story Chris good morning
good morning that mugshot sure is
eye-catching now think about this you're
at your gate getting ready to board your
flight when your pilot is led away in
handcuffs the prime suspect in a three
year old murder case this happened on
Saturday as Christian Martin was getting
ready to fly a plane load of people from
the Louisville Airport to North Carolina
that's when the cops swooped in
Christian Martin was still in his pilot
uniform when police snapped this booking
photo after arresting him for triple
murder
these were three individuals that are
that are gone and are never coming back
and and that deserve justice Kentucky
Attorney General Andy Beshear says in
November 2015
Martin allegedly killed Calvin and
Pamela Phillips and their neighbor
Edward dancer Oh Calvin Phillips was
found shot in his Pembroke Kentucky home
the bodies of his wife and dancera were
discovered a few miles away in a
cornfield inside her burned-out car
Martin was dishonorably discharged in an
interview with CNN Matt Phillips says
his father was killed before he could
testify in a court-martial trial against
Martin he was shamefully kicked out of
the military my father had a lot to do
with that Martin was reportedly a person
of interest immediately following the
killings but in a 2016 interview with a
local TV station he denied being
involved I don't know why anybody want
to do something to them
Martin was hired as a first officer in
2018 for PSA a regional carrier owned by
American Airlines in a statement
American says pilots undergo a criminal
background check and recurrent vetting
for any derogatory information statement
adds Martin did not have any criminal
history that would disqualify him from
being a commercial pilot martin remains
behind bars this morning it is unclear
if he has a lawyer yet and we were
unable to reach Martin American Airlines
has put the 51 year-old
pilot on administrative suspension
basically grounding him until his court
case is resolved Nora what a story Chris
thank you Chris painted quite a picture
you're standing there as a passenger and
they were leading your pilot away in
handcuffs you know this is a big problem
hey buckaroo